this morning we have more of CBS News
exclusive interview with the Navy
secretary who was fired over his
handling of a Navy SEALs war crimes case
the seal that's Edward Gallagher was
convicted of posing with a dead Isis
fighter in Iraq and demoted but the
president reversed that decision and on
Monday the Navy canceled a review board
that could have forced Gallagher to
leave the seals as he left the Pentagon
yesterday for the final time Spencer
argued president Trump's intervention
sets a bad precedent he also suggested
the president doesn't fully understand
the fighting force that he commands
David Martin is at the Pentagon for us
David how did we get here well this case
of Edward Gallagher is about more than
just whether he would be allowed to keep
the Trident pin that identifies him as a
Navy SEAL it cost the Secretary of the
Navy his job and as he left this
building for the last time he told CBS
News what was at stake what do I stand
for Secretary of the Navy good order and
discipline of the United States Navy
that's a prime tenant this in fact
erodes that former Navy secretary
Richard Spencer told CBS News that
President Trump's decision to intervene
in the Gallagher case sends a dangerous
message to the troops that you can get
away with things we have to have good
order and discipline it's the backbone
of what we do
Spencer was fired by defense secretary
mark espera for going behind his back in
an attempt to work out a deal that would
convince the president he didn't need to
intervene as for spoke with reporters
off-camera secretary Spencer had
proposed a deal whereby the president
allowed the Navy to handle the case he
would guarantee that Eddie Gallagher
would be restored the rank allowed the
retainers Trident and permitted the
retire
according to Spencer the response from
White House lawyers was quote nope POTUS
will be involved you know arguably he
doesn't have to deal with anyone he did
and he said I'm gonna be involved
Gallagher was demoted after he was
convicted of posing for photos with a
dead Isis fighter yesterday President
Trump told reporters he stepped in to
restore Gallagher's rank and let him
keep his Trident in order to stand up
for warrior
and the decisions they have to make on
the battlefield I don't think he really
understands the full definition of a
warfighter warfighter is a profession of
arms and a profession of arms has
standards that they have to be held to
and they hold themselves to Spenser
Warren Gallagher's case was about more
than just one Navy Seal the special
operating community has been put under
amazing pressure to do amazing things
and they're amazing performing people
but there's ramifications that happen
with that and we have to build a system
around it that has discipline people
look up to us and go yes they actually
stick by what they say and they take the
higher ground you think in this case the
US has not stuck by what it said to date
I think it has but an action like this
aroused that about the same time Spencer
left the Pentagon Gallagher was being
informed by his command in Coronado
California that he would
allowed to retire on
where is pride meanwhile a post appeared
on Edward and Andrea Gallagher's
Instagram page it showed a picture of a
dumpster fire with a caption that read
current state of Navy leadership Eureka
David Martin force at the Pentagon thank
you